I crossed paths with somebody who worked
at Microsoft Research who was working in
virtual reality and I didn't even know
what that was I didn't even know what
email was and he invited me to come in
and see this world and I remember they
had me log in as an avatar and run
across the world and be interviewed by
other avatars this is at Microsoft
Research in 1997 and they were like are
you interested in building worlds with
us and I was like I don't even
understand what is happening right now
but I want to yes of course you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen using Oscar rose way has a
formal title its principal research
designer in the HCI group at Microsoft
Research but she's also been described
as a conductor an alchemist a millennial
in a gen-xers body and in her own words
a fusionist what's a fusionist you might
ask we are about to find out on today's
podcast hasta gives us an inside look at
one of the most unconventional labs at
Microsoft Research located at the
intersection of science technology and
art it's a lab that insists that
technology like art should push
boundaries tell stories and feed our
souls get ready for the unexpected
because when hasta asks what if you're
likely to find yourself immersed in a
world of responsive clothing smart
tattoos talking plants and even
environmentally sensitive makeup that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
hasta Rose way welcome to the podcast
thank you thank you for having me I'm
excited to have you here today I am do
and I actually don't like using the word
excited oh it's the new amazing
absolutely everything is exciting
nothing's exciting exactly really I'm
excited yay so your official title is
principal research designer in the HCI
group at Microsoft Research but you also
call yourself a fusionist so what is a
fusionist what does a fusionist do and
what gets a fusionist up in the morning
all right so I have always been a bit of
an outlier my whole life and I've never
been very comfortable with formal labels
and I have found that some of the roles
and the paths that I've been on have
been so unconventional that I feel like
I needed a title to actually help me
explain it to myself does that make
sense
totally and so I find myself working
between disciplines and fields I'm
coming at it from a sort of an art brain
but I've been in computer science for
almost 15 years and I'm like how do I
pull all of these things together and
like fusion i fuse things together that
is my process so I wanted something
where I can just say in a quick elevator
pitch
hey I'm a fusionist that's what I do as
in latex question them suffer with it
right like let them figure it out does
anyone ever ask you what suffusion us
yeah they do all the time you got that
but the thing is is they kind of get it
I'm like it's art it's tacit science I'm
pulling all of these aspects together
this sort of pushed this next wave and
and they go okay yeah and I've had a lot
of young folks go I would like to be a
fusionist to you situate your research
actually at the intersection of art
technology in science which is a super
interesting intersection as far as I'm
concerned what big questions might we
come closer to answering or big problems
that we might come closer to solving if
we live at that intersection I like this
question you know we have two
hemispheres to our brain we have the
right in the left it's there for a
reason
it formulates the holistic picture of
we are and how we function in the world
I feel like without that balance we
can't approach the next wave of problems
being a hundred percent mindful about it
and if you only paint a picture with a
certain palette of colors you're just
missing out on the rest of the spectrum
that's there to be used so for me it's
like this is an opportunity to take on
the really hard things climate change
environmental impacts that we have even
humanities and how we can integrate that
other part of ourselves they actually
start tackling these hard problems how
are you finding that to be received by
this very computational stem oriented
math privileged culture without your
head well to me I'm kind of like a
weeble wobble
okay the harder you push me the harder I
push back and I love the challenge and I
actually find inspiration and inspiring
my colleagues and people around me to
also open up that part of their brain
that side of themselves it's like oh you
know if you take it from this
perspective it's so different and all of
a sudden the traditional obstacles kind
of melt away because you're kind of
coming at it from a different angle so
to me I take great pleasure in helping
my colleagues join in in that
conversation and encouraging them to
cross collaborate and try it from a
different angle so I'm okay with that
now I've got weebles wobble but they
don't fall down stuck in my head song
actually probably dates me are you
seeing a shift in receptivity to this
kind of thinking yeah I am I would
actually say that in the last five years
things have really shifted in a way that
has enabled me to continue this work to
grow this platform I've also seen it in
the waves of young people and interns
coming in they kind of come at it from
the same mindset so I feel like I'm
finding my kindred spirits it just feels
so reinforcing you know just oh this
feels good they get
and they want it and they want to know
how to do it so I feel like we're kind
of inspiring each other which is
fascinating and I see more and more of
them coming in as the years roll by what
about the not new people but the old
school you know hey look everyone has
their place and their function and their
purpose and that is totally fine for me
I have my own way of coming in to a
conversation and a project and I
encourage them to get ready for this
next generation because this next
generation is a different breed yes it
is an entirely different breed so if
they come to me my colleagues say hey
I've got this hybrid intern sound of to
me I'll talk with them let's figure out
a way for them to kind of integrate lots
of research begins with the question
what if but when you ask if it's really
whatever it often ends up in sort of
what you'd call unconventional
explorations of human-computer
interaction so yeah what's different
about how you approach technology
research what's different about when you
ask what if okay I'll use this analogy
for me the what-if is like me jumping
out of an airplane I have no idea where
I'm gonna land I just know I want to get
out of the airplane I want to jump and I
want to give it a shot and that means
that you know in traditional research
you know you work on sort of these
iterations of learnings and
understandings for me it's been more
about okay I see this trend over here
and then this thing is happening over
here but these things I've never met in
the middle so what if they do what
happens then and so that's the driver I
just feel like I want to be a magnet and
just kind of bring both sides together
you established Microsoft's first-ever
artist-in-residence program called
Studio 99 and I have to ask why do we
need artists in high tech research okay
okay so first of all let's pull this
back why do we need art that feeds our
soul right art has been with us since
the beginning of time
it tells stories and narratives
creates memories and it fuels that side
of us it lives in each one of us and so
why wouldn't it be a part of our tech in
our research culture it has to be it's a
part of that dance that we have to have
with that other side of ourselves so
that we can ask these questions like
well how does this impact our society
how does this impact the individual how
does this technology impact our privacy
and art has this way of just shoving it
in our faces and really asking the hard
questions so what kinds of things are
happening in the artist-in-residence
program here in the past we did
something around if you think of
Internet of Things and how our
environment is sort of moving towards
this world where things are talking to
each other whether it's devices like my
card my refrigerator we wanted to go way
beyond that so we wanted to do human to
plants human to interspecies and why not
I mean artists are the ones that are
like of course we should be able to talk
to plants and animals
isn't that what technology should
facilitate right when that enable us to
have healthier conversations with our
environment so we did a project called
Project Florence which was the
brainchild of Helena Steiner who had a
background in plant signaling and design
and her approach was I want to make
plants respond to us I want what we say
to impact them in some way we have done
some explorations with
computer-generated art and sort of
playing in the way with algorithms can
sort of manifest the art my very
favorite is we had a young woman come in
with a background in bio fabrication and
that is sort of the emergence of new
materials from living matter and so she
had a passion around mushrooms and
mycelium cultures and she actually grew
her wedding dress out of mycelium
and I was like yeah let's do this
her name is Erin Smith you should look
her up she's pretty sweet so she came in
and worked with us on something called
growable x' like why wouldn't the next
wave of the things on our bodies be
alive it was so out there it was like
something out of a David Cronenberg
but I loved it because it made people
just stop for a minute and go wait a
second
so wearables don't have to be plastic
they don't have to be driven by a
battery they can be alive they can be
honest I loved it how did it work out
did she actually grow a mushroom wedding
dress a fungus dress she grew so she
sorry she threw the dress on her own
time like this was before she came work
for us but she ended up actually growing
these amulets into petri dishes and we
displayed them and for me it was so
great to see my colleagues my peers come
and look at this stuff and go oh my gosh
like I hadn't even thought of this
that's why we have these kind of
programs so as soon as you said that she
was growing mushrooms to do a dress I
thought well she'll grow them and then
pick them and make the dress somewhat
like Lady Gaga's meat dress but you're
talking about it being a living thing
yeah so there's two facets to that one
is her approach was she wanted to create
a material from the mycelium itself that
would then be decomposed right because
wedding dresses are made of polyester
and they're just adding to the landfill
so she wanted to kind of change that
paradigm the second part of it is there
is this whole world of new materials
that we are just beginning to understand
on the micro level even on the chemistry
level and these are sort of the next
wave of the intelligence and how it
permeates into our everyday lives it's
pretty cool
[Music]
hasta we can't do justice to the visual
nature of the work you do on a podcast
although maybe your group could get to
work on that you come from on it all
kinds of things are going through my
head right now but I'll encourage our
listeners to hit up the website and look
you up because it's amazing stuff
thank you but let's dig into a few of
the projects that typify your work
starting with what's been called your
breakthrough design it was Microsoft's
first fashion technology piece it won
Best in Show at the international
symposium of wearable computers I didn't
even know there was one and was featured
at CES South by Southwest and New York
Fashion Week tell us about the printing
dress the printing dress I love this you
know I had reached a place in my career
where I had been working as a sort of a
user experience designer and I felt like
everything I did was stuck in a square
and I kind of had this weird crisis of
like how do I get out of this box and so
I remember I was doing just some
internet browsing and I came across this
piece from Philips research it was this
mood dress it was so beautiful and
inspiring there was something deep in me
that was like yes and I couldn't even
articulate to anyone what was going on
with that I was just like this is great
I want more of this how do I do this and
so I decided you know I have a
background in design I've done some
sewing in the past like I'll give it a
shot
I partnered up with a colleague of mine
Sheridan Martin small who had a
background in engineering and we got
together and we just thought let's just
do this what's the worst that can happen
we just pulled together extra time we
built this dress we submitted it to this
symposium and all I wanted to do was
just manifest that was the goal
it wasn't even beyond that it was like
can we just take something from 2d to 3d
and that's how it started and it's been
a rabbit hole ever since and I am
grateful for it
so grateful well tell me about it
because when you say the printing dress
and I've seen some pictures of it in an
article is it a printing oh yeah it did
or so it's a dress made entirely of
paper and that's by design
and it looks like something out of the
1900s so it has a very retro feel to it
very Victorian it's got a capacitive
keyboard corset that's kind of built
into the bodice and it enables people to
actually type and tweet their feelings
and thoughts and as they do we had a
projector set up underneath it that
would actually display all the thoughts
and animate as memories so the goal of
the dress was to speak to the notion of
what happens when accountability and
privacy and wearable technology and
social networks they all sort of meet in
the middle like if you talk trash you
wear trash you know that was the message
it's kind of relevant today don't you
think more so now than ever you know
every day it gets more and more relevant
right it was really supposed to be a
thought piece but also it was my wish to
actually bring something like that to
Microsoft like I wanted a dress to exist
inside the building why not another
wearable project you did yeah was called
litewear and this was an exploration and
wearable light therapy tell us about
that project what was the rationale
behind it what happened with it and what
were the research takeaways from that
experience so litewear was a project
that I worked on with an intern by the
name of Hallie Profeta
and she and I were really interested in
this intersection between wellness and
wearables and where is the sweet spot
and so we were both pretty cognizant of
the fact that you know seasonal
affective disorder is really a thing and
it really does impact millions of people
and we wanted to explore the light that
was coming out of these light boxes and
just get rid of the box again my issue
with squares and I was like can we just
get the light out of here and put it in
something else and that began to kind of
instantiate as scarves glasses or hats
and we used the same light spectrum from
the box into the garments but we just
had a lower intensity so a standard
light box you might sit in front of for
30 minutes because it has a very high
intensity for the scarf you might wrap
it around yourself and you'll get the
light from the fiber optics inside the
scarf but at a lower intensity so you
might wear it for two hours or an hour
on the bus but we wanted something that
frees you & untethered you from the box
and you can sort of transcend that
feeling of oh I'm stuck behind a box so
you want to use fashion as sort of this
way to escalate and make people feel
good while they're getting healed what a
concept so what happened so we worked on
several instantiations of it we did user
studies we got a lot of great feedback
from people who actually really loved it
and we were able to sort of do a
publication in pervasive health and it
actually got best paper so that was
amazing and then from there you know
it's one of those kind of projects where
you might have an expectation for how it
should evolve and be received and yet
it's all about the timing our people
collectively ready to grab onto a
concept like this I don't know and it
didn't seem so at the time but I promise
you you will see the things like this in
the future I believe it was it the
people who suffered from seasonal
affective disorder that weren't ready to
receive it or the people who were
looking at the people wearing a light-up
scarf it might have been both it's
really hard to say you know that's the
challenging thing about trying to ride
the wave a little bit ahead of the curve
like you just don't know how things will
be received right and you don't know if
it was you know our people just feeling
a little bit like that's too much
attention drawn on themselves right
because it's not like you see people
wearing light around themselves ever so
it there's a
of things to consider with that but it
was a fascinating project one of the
coolest things you're working on is
called duo skin or smart tattoos which
is literally wearable technology that
becomes part of your skin
tell us about smart tattoos including
the history with MIT Media Lab and the
very recent mini hackathon you hosted
called Hackett at so do skin was started
at Microsoft Research with my intern
Cindy Cao from the Media Lab it was
really sort of an interesting approach
to the e tattoos that we had seen sort
of surfacing and eat at OU's are more
medicinal that are sort of very very
high ends there's built in laboratories
and they might be sort of something that
you put on a patient to monitor a pulse
but these kind of technologies are just
impossible to get ahold of and they're
very blackbox and how they're made so we
thought let's just take that notion of
smart temporary transitory technologies
and we fuse that together I'm using that
word with jewelry and accessories and
all of the jewelry tattoos that were
starting to come on to the market at the
time and we think back specifically to
Beyonce's the launch of her jewelry
tattoos and we were completely inspired
so we were like how do you take
something beautiful like this and give
it purpose and functionality and that
was the origin of dual skin and how that
came about and since then can Microsoft
research we've been actually working on
the next generation of materials ways
that we can enable people to fabricate
and build their own and so we're looking
into ways we can create kits and that
was what sort of brought about the
hackathon and the Hacket at where we
invited people from across the company
to come and build these tattoos play
with them give us feedback and sort of
help us along the journey because we
can't think of every scenario and so the
feedback was just wonderful it was
completely eye-opening what kinds of
people showed up at the hack attack I
would say Millennials again with the
young people yeah um you know they were
just super excited to just think outside
the box controllers don't have to be
standard controls I can make anything
interactive I can put a sticker on my
water bottle and
have it do something for me or I can put
something on my clothes and all of a
sudden it has a purpose so I think they
loved the creative expressivity of it
but also just the freedom of thinking
outside of that norm so give me an
example of what if I put a smart tattoo
on my arm yeah
what's my interface do I work the tattoo
from my device or do I work my device
from the tattoo or is there no device or
was so the tattoo is connected to a
small microprocessor that has a small
battery and then you we use a Bluetooth
radio to connect to the devices so you
can connect it to anything with
bluetooth and that's where the
creativity and the scenarios come in
right and that's why we wanted to get it
into people's hands to let them dream
big and think of the things they wanted
to do with it because we can't think of
it all we talked about this a little but
I want to go a little deeper thinking
about the Internet of Things and
obviously when we think of it we think
of being able to communicate with our
devices or having our devices
communicate with each other which is
slightly more scary if you ask me yeah
but your thinking is different even from
there and you alluded to project
Florence where you did a dr. Doolittle
kind of thing only with flora not fauna
tell us a little bit more about that out
there thinking and are there any other
sort of Internet of Things ideas
percolating that you're allowed to talk
to us about yeah you know again like
part of my secret agenda is I'm always
excited to make people feel slightly
uncomfortable and nervous about a new
sort of story that's unfolding in front
of them and I know we had chatted about
this a little earlier about storytelling
and how important it is that you have
the right voices in the room to actually
start to tell a different kind of story
about our future and the drive and the
inspiration for Florence was
what if we were able to tell a story
where we were interfacing with our
plants or animals our environment in a
way that actually raises awareness about
what is going on with it and what we can
learn from it because nature is this
incredible entity that is so infinitely
complex it makes your head spin and yet
it all kind of works magically and
there's so much to emulate from that and
I want to drive these new narratives for
people that don't resonate with the
current one I want people to wake up in
the morning and say oh my gosh I had
never thought the future like this and
that actually resonates with the way I
feel about it
and I want to tell my story too so
that's a lot of the driving factor
behind this so we started out talking
about technology and fashion in this
projects part of the podcast let's wrap
up on this section with technology and
makeup right tell us about this project
called earth tones what is it why would
we need it and where might it lead I
love this this is one of my near and
dear it's one of those kind of quieter
projects that kind of lives under the
radar that has been slowly growing on
its own but the idea is we put things on
our body every day you know whether it's
shampoo it's cream whatnot and why
wouldn't we enable these things to act
as notifications as sensors things that
would raise our awareness about what
we're being exposed to on a daily basis
and UV is a perfect example so every day
we get exposed to UV levels whether it's
cloudy or not and what if we had a way
that things on our face or our hair
could change color could enable us to
actually see the impact of this exposure
to understand that there's a threshold
that we shouldn't go beyond what I loved
about the earth tones was it was a very
earnest attempt
to show the unseen in a way that could
manifest in everyday habitual practices
by people all over the world and I loved
the analog color changing nature of it
it was something that you could do
without batteries and I love that so
tell me what it is
so essentially era tones was the idea of
blush powders that could then turn
deeper shades of color depending on how
much exposure you are getting from
carbon monoxide or UV rays so it was
sort of like watching your face change
in pigments throughout the course of the
day and a lot of people would say I
don't want my face changing color in
front of people and then a lot of people
would say I'm okay with that actually
it's kind of punk rock I love it I kind
of want to like make a statement and
then there's this other part of it that
is about the awareness like I didn't
know that we were being exposed to this
much every day how is that impacting my
health these are the things we don't
think about until we're sick so how do
we give out this sort of slow awakening
of things that we just do every day to
something that can say maybe it's time
for you to consider how you're gonna
take care of yourself right so what
about future applications and thinking's
about what we put on ourselves as
sensors I am excited about programmable
materials I'm excited about the promises
that chemistry brings I'm excited about
creating intelligent layers on things
that normally would be completely missed
by everyday people and that's that
element of shock and surprise when it's
not powered by a battery it's profound
so one of my favorite aphorisms is that
when scientists make a really important
discovery they don't say Eureka
they say that's strange and by now I'm
kind of like that must be what auste
says all day every day but whether
that's true or not
it's the strangest thing that you've
discovered as a fusionist here at MSR
the strangest thing I I am gonna have to
go back to the mushrooms
I mean seriously growing wearable
amulets and petri dishes was pretty far
on the spectrum for me it was definitely
considering spores from mushrooms
possibly getting out just ways to sort
of manage the life force of these things
still remains the most out-there thing
I've ever dipped my toes into but I I
have no regrets at all well I will say
this having seen many of the videos on
your page on the Microsoft Research
website there's a lot of out there stuff
that you've seen and been a part of so
that's pretty my threshold for out there
is pretty high so this is why if you see
the other stuff I consider normal the
stuff that really makes my head noodle
is still remains in a petri dish I hear
you
because I'm way over on the other side
of the spectrum like weird is you know
wearing a color
[Laughter]
[Music]
so let's go back to labels for a minute
and I think this is really important
aside from fusionist some people have
called you a conductor the symphony
metaphor you've referred to yourself as
an alchemist and one of my favorites is
I'm a millennial and in Gen Xers body
totally first of all unpack what you
mean by this a bit and then talk about
how self conceptualization or identity
might impact a person's perception maybe
their ability to carry out work in this
industry let's start with going back to
the notion that I've never been able to
fit into conventional pockets and I've
used that as a strength and that enables
me to then transcend labels for me it's
always been don't put me in a corner
don't try to figure it out cuz I'm still
trying to figure it out
and I laugh about the Millennial thing
because I have never been in this line
of work to get the big things that
people think are important I live a
pretty minimal life and I feel like what
moves me what drives me is to make
change and I think the Millennials get
that and I think they want that too and
I am NOT inspired by the big promotions
I'm not inspired by the big titles
I just want change and so I'll just do
whatever it takes I will rattle any cage
to make that happen I ask all my guests
this question and I'll ask you to given
the breadth of what you do and the
general landscape of the industry is
there anything that keeps you up at
night oh there's so much that gives me
up at night there's kind of two folds to
that question the first is that feeling
that change isn't happening fast enough
you push push push push you do
everything you can is it enough is it
enough like are we going to be able to
dig ourselves out from all these things
that
present these challenges to us
collectively those things keep me up at
night and you try to think to yourself
today how can I push the needle a little
bit more so that's one aspect of it and
then the other aspect is that you just
hope that whatever it is that you bring
and push will actually change something
fundamentally in a way that transcends
all your hopes that you really change
someone's life in a profound way and
maybe it's just the fact that I'm here
that is inspiring a next wave of young
people to consider a path in their
career if that's the legacy I leave and
it's not a product or it's not a
technology then I'll take it so that's a
perfect segue into my last question as
we wrap up you're part of a relatively
small tribe here at Microsoft Research
in that computer science isn't your
background or your training so what was
your education path and how did you end
up here at Microsoft Research what does
it say to people who might not assume
there's a place for them in high tech
yeah I love this so my path was
traditional design I mean I grew up in a
family of artists and musicians we
didn't even have a traditional working
desk in the house I mean everybody was
just either making music or art so of
course I found my way into graphic
design and I went to Parsons School of
Design and my initial goal was to end up
you know maybe in a big design company
maybe working in marketing or
advertising and it was the most bizarre
thing another rabbit-hole situation
where I crossed paths with somebody who
worked in Microsoft Research who was
working in virtual reality and at the
time you have to think of this as a
mid-90s oh you're kidding No
so this was the mid-90s he was like
we're working in virtual reality I
didn't even know what that was I didn't
even know what email was okay I was one
of the very first classes to come out
with you know having enough experience
working on a computer making art from a
computer that I could understand that
there was some appeal there and he
invited me to come
and see this world and I remember they
had me login as an avatar and run across
the world and be interviewed by other
avatars this is at Microsoft Research in
1997 and they were like are you
interested in building worlds with us
and I was like I don't even understand
what is happening right now
but I want to yes of course and it's
that desire that passion that excitement
for these unknown spaces that has been
the catalyst in my life that has pushed
me into these holes and they keep going
deeper and I've never looked back and
this is why I have always considered
myself to be a bit of an outlier because
I end up in these situations that I
can't even predict or foresee and that's
the wave I ride so what would you say to
this generation many of whom are in
undergraduate or even graduate school
that might not think hey high tech is a
natural fit for my affinities and my
abilities so part of the big motivation
for the work that I do is to show them
that they can play in this space just by
the fact that I exist and I'm here doing
it it should be a signal to them that
they can too and I take a lot of pride
in showing them hey you know technology
and the future can look like this it
doesn't have to look like what you think
it does it can look like something you
feel it does and so I use myself as an
example I'm shameless about that and
people you know ping me on LinkedIn or
they send me emails they ask me like how
how can I do this and I tell them two
things first is these kind of jobs won't
initially be there when you get there
you have to do it yourself you have to
build this way of working yourself you
can't expect them to know what you need
and want you have to show them and the
second is be ready for anything because
you may think that you don't have a role
to play but something can change
fundamentally
tomorrow it absolutely makes you
critical so don't underestimate your own
skills and your value because we don't
know what the future is gonna ask for
hasta Rose way thank you
oh you're so welcome to learn more about
hasta Rose way and our fusionist future
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]